hey where's and why does Elena minam
little ain't no way let us know let us
know let us know hey what's going on
YouTube now learning to use a public
restroom without fear is probably one of
these biggest hurdles in life that you
have to get over especially if your why
are you a because a male's public
restroom is [ __ ] disgusting ah ladies
can I ask you something have you ever
walked into one before hmm
it's where nightmare pee and taking the
Dukes in a public restroom it's like
rolling dice you don't know what the
[ __ ] you're gonna get I'm on break what
is going on what I don't know this
applies to women per se but I'm saying
that when the man walks into a public
restroom suddenly they forget where
their dick is you can do this god damn
it they miss the whole [ __ ] toilet
there's a certain amount of grace that
you get on how much you're allowed to
let a piss miss you see what a guy takes
a piss and it's a new toilet that they
haven't used they kind of have to do a
tester plug little tester
there you go there you go buddy then
after you test it you should
automatically understand the distance
and the velocity in which you should pee
yeah tenon good boy but for some reason
there's always a ridiculous amount of
pee pull at the base of the toilet why
do you know what that means it means you
didn't do your tester you were all cocky
huh
copy that you knew what the [ __ ] you
were doing but obviously you did it
because when you came out of the toilet
you're just done okay and I think I got
this one
God like what the [ __ ] where did you go
mom who pees like that what's your dig
up a [ __ ] soda can like and you might
even ask these people well why don't you
just go back and clean it cuz more
likely than not you're not the only one
using a public restroom so there's
somebody outside your stall so when you
walk out and you make an awkward eye
contact you act like it was bad before
you did and can we please talk about the
people that leave the Dukes in the
toilet why is it your [ __ ] calling
card
you're not making soup [ __ ] you don't
need assay to flush the [ __ ] thing
and your [ __ ] always leave the
largest [ __ ] in the [ __ ] toilet right
when somebody else has to take a poop oh
[ __ ] so at the end of the day fellas
it's not that hard it's something you do
every day
no more stains learn to a it's a public
restroom it's not your [ __ ] house
everybody uses it you act like you've
are morning wood and you try to aim in
the toilet oh and by the way ladies in
case you didn't know when a guy's think
it's harder he tries to piss in the
toilet it's like it's difficult it's
like trying to solve a Rubik's Cube
[ __ ] nah-ah
the more you know oh honey of mail even
adela t nada